wir hatten den eindruck das ist ein
gewisses bedürfnis möglicherweise auch
nach bayern geben könnte und haben
deswegen ein urgestein gesprochen
nämlich waldemar hartmann den früheren
langjährigen fußball kommentator und
haben mit ihm über markus wieder
gesprochen wir unser gespräch oder
andere weise
sie kennen den markus söder schon eine
ganze weile erzählen sie uns mal seit
wann und vielleicht erinnern sie sich
noch an das eine oder andere aus dieser
zeit also richtig kennt ihn seit 1992
das habe ich deswegen im kopfball markus
damals angefangen hat beim bayerischen
fernsehen in einer politischen sendung
als redakteur und ich wurde gerade
redaktionsleiter sport beim bayerischen
fernsehen
und es gibt eine schöne geschichte das
hat irgendwie mal erzählt da bin ich in
der kantine an seinem tisch vorbei
gegangen wo er mit seinen kollegen von
der politik saß und sagte den kollegen
eigentlich weniger sportreporter
geworden er ist ja wirklich großer wenn
das erste fc nürnberg und deswegen auch
leidensweg im übrigen und so sagten die
kollegen zu ihm aber doch nicht bei dem
das ist doch ein gnadenlos harter hund
warum und ergriffen dann hat gekniffen
vor ihnen daher gesagt dass ich sein
lassen und ich habe ihn darauf gefragt
kann ich das verwenden du hast mal angst
vor mir und das hat er frei gegeben
deswegen darf ich die geschichte hier zu
helfen und dann ist daraus eine ganz
andere karriere geworden nämlich eine
politische trauen sie dem zu dass der
kanzler wird also ich könnte jetzt sagen
ich traue ihm alles zu und deswegen
glaube ich ihm auch zu dass er kanzler
wird man muss es aber auch den wählern
zutrauen dass sie ihn wählen und
mittlerweile nach den umfragen auch den
von heute kann man davon ausgehen dass
die mehrheit das gar nicht so schlecht
findet
jetzt ist das sehr kompliziert mit cdu
und csu wie man das dann so ein fehlt
warum ist das eigentlich so schwierig
warum kann er nicht einfach wie
schröders früher gemacht hat jetzt sich
hinstellen meinetwegen auch vor den zaun
vom kanzleramt und sagen weißt doch
sowieso jeder ich will da rein
ja weil mehr rein wollen von der cdu
wir sind ja jetzt 3 bekannt die das
wollen herr laschet ersparen und röttgen
von der cdu hieß und muss sich jetzt
keine melden denn wir dürfen die
reihenfolge nicht verwechseln zuerst mit
der vorsitzende der cdu im dezember
gewählt und dann wird man bestimmen wer
der kanzlerkandidat der beiden
schwesterparteien zusammen ist da ist
nicht längst klar werden darüber in der
sendung schon diskutiert ist es nicht
längst klar dass die eigentlich keine
chance haben gegen den söder jetzt nach
der korona krise der steht ja geradezu
ja fast wie fast königlich da im moment
eher weise sie sagen ist wie nach der
korona krise hätten sie in eure
nachgeblättert in den umfragen im
oktober des letzten jahres als die cdu
selber auch noch so um 25 prozent herum
schwankt da hat kein mensch und markus
söder gesprochen das ist ja erst während
und nach der korona käse die noch nicht
beweis entstanden weil sie
offensichtlich in den augen der leute
bürgerinnen und bürger perfekt gehandelt
hat das hat ihnen nach oben gebracht
aber es kann so viel passieren bis zum
dezember bis zum parteitag und gewählt
wird nächstes jahr im herbst also da
kann auch passieren stand heute sage ich
er ist die geeignete gibt es was bei den
sie sagen würden dass das typisch markus
zuwider
ich glaube das brauchst du der politik
du musst ein ziel haben
sein ziel war von anfang an ich will
bayerische ministerpräsident werden
deswegen so in die politik gegangen und
das habe konsequent verfolgt da kriegt
man auch ein bisschen haut an den
ellenbogen aber sagen sie mir den
spitzenpolitiker der die nicht dass uns
wäre kleiner geworden
diese konsequenz das befolgen eines
ziels das hat er jetzt auch bei corona
bewiesen das ist seine große stärke
seine gegner sagen das ist auch eine
schwäche aber ich betrachte diese stärke
er ist auf jeden fall ein ganz anderer
typ als angela merkel ich glaube das ist
schon rein äußerlich sehr sehr schnell
erkennbar aber auch inhaltlich oder vom
vom charakter was würden sie sagen was
kann der besser als merkel und was kann
der vielleicht schlechter als merk
frau merkel hat natürlich eine
regierungs erfahren von 15 jahren und
zwar in ganz großen spiel
sie musste mit theresa may leben
sie musste mit putin und immer noch
leben sie musste mit drum leben konnte
mit obama ganz gut dieses ganz großen
spiel kann markus söder ja nicht kennen
er kennt bisher das bayerische aber er
hat gezeigt wenn der spielfeldgröße wird
dann kann man sich auch gut bewegen ich
glaube was angela merkel jetzt gesagt
hat in der ruhe liegt die kraft bei
augen kleiner hinweis an ihn ein
bisschen mehr ruhe und ein bisschen
weniger kraft posing und ein bisschen
mehr bedachtsamkeit also ja jetzt vor
einer woche ein interview gegeben in
einer berliner zeitung wo er die
kriterien für einen guten kanzler
bekanntgegeben hat aus meiner sicht der
dass sich das sparen können weil es hat
irgendwie ja doch den hut in den ring
geworfen und das hört und sieht man dass
man bei der cdu nicht so gerne vielen
dank dass sie uns zugeschaltet waren hat
man stücken abend